The Joe Rogan Experience the different
ways of approaching comedy it's it's got
to parallel with music right I mean
there's got to be some artists that you
know they just want to riff they want to
figure it out on the Fly they want to do
it all you know almost off the top of
their head and then there's other
artists where every single word is gone
over and meticulously analyzed and
pieced together yeah there's no right
right or wrong way and you just have to
find your way yeah whatever works for
you yeah
um
yeah I've worked with artists who do it
completely different ways you know
you'll see like Eminem will he's always
writing in a book always writing
all the time and he's always got
notebooks writing and I I asked him it's
like of these all you know Rhymes
Tuesday he's like no no he's like
99 of what I write I'll never use just
to stay engaged in the process of of
writing
and finding new ways to write so that it
just when I need it it just comes and
then
um Jay-Z would doesn't write anything
down yeah and he just listens to the
beat and hums hums and then goes into
the goes on the mic you know 20 minutes
later and just says a whole complicated
very complicated verse I don't know how
I don't know how he can
remember it much like much less have
just written it
and just be able to do it like free it's
crazy does he practice on his own does
he does he
create these wraps on his own with like
alone or does he only do it when he's
talking to people or does he only do it
on stage no no this is this is on for a
record like when we were recording 99
problems I played the beat for him
he likes the beat and then he says okay
just keep playing it and then he sits in
the back of the control room on the
couch
and he's and you just hear him humming
like hmm
[Music]
as I say 15 or 20 minutes and then he
jumps I was like okay I got it and then
he goes in no no paper no writing
nothing
and delivers the whole thing and then
says let's try it again and then he does
it again and the words will be the same
but the phrasing will be different so
it's more like
um an improvisational solo you know if
you have a Melody you could play the
same Melody
with uh putting emphasis on different
parts of it so he does it it's not the
same the words are the same or close to
the same
but the feeling of it and the rhythm of
it changes when he does it again and he
does it a few times and he's like okay I
think that one's good
and but did you ever ask him these
things that he's saying has he said them
before does he he's not I know he hasn't
because it's it's happening live in the
room in this moment so but it's not like
he's not recite he's not even though
it's live in the moment it's not like
things that he's thought about before
just all off the top yes wow yes isn't
that incredible it's insane the same
thing like it that's incredible yeah
he's famous for that he's famous for
having it all in his head
but instantaneously or you know
relatively instantaneously
does anybody else do it like that like
no I've not seen Nas I've never seen
anyone else do that do that
wow it's not uncommon for singers or
rappers to hear something and
immediately start like automatic writing
where they'll just start saying nonsense
words yeah the first thing that comes to
mind over the over the beat where you
can feel a shape of what it can be yeah
and like um we just made two new albums
with the Chili Peppers that the second
one is just came
just coming out now I think but the
first one came out like six months ago
but two double albums and the way
Anthony works is he'll hear the music
and he'll sing along but he'll sing
along with an idea of a Melody but he
doesn't yet have words and just sing
nonsense words and just sing along
making up nonsense words
automatically real time and then listens
back and says okay this phrase in this
spot sounds good and this phrase in this
spot sounds good what else goes with
that and then it's like a puzzle where
you fill in the rests like you you don't
necessarily have an idea what the song's
going to be about or you might not even
know what song's about until you finish
you might not even know after the song's
finished what it's about you might not
know for years what it's about because
it's like a dream you know it comes from
the subconscious yeah
it's a great way to work it's a great
way to write to um
just like participate with what's going
on in a free way
and then listen back to what you did and
look for Clues look for where where is
the connective tissue here are there any
things here that
that sound like they belong there